‏pleas make
goal
here and up sister you take care of it
mus be before the starts so going take
more minut
‏and sister if you guys want to conate
and a b there a 24 scen up you can watch
the sal from there is
ோக்ஸ்டேஸ்
[Silence]
ইতবা 40
মিনিট অফ
[Silence]
ي
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
والله اكبر
ولله
الله اكبر
الله الحمد
الله
اكبر اله الا الله
الله اكبر
الله الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
মিনিপার
ভলক মিনিপার
ভেল ব্লকিং
পিপল
জাক আল্লাহু আকবার
لا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر اله الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
‏com you
have no more space available in the back
we are lally to the so if coming in
pleas
out
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وعزم
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد
وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وسلم تسليم
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
‏sister can you pleas stand up for
little give us little more space because
definely a capacity isue but i think we
still have some room in this h that we
can accomodate few more so if those who
can stand up and move little b just to
make sure we create
accodat standing in
the while we are adjusting our r i just
অফ ইউ
পজ আহমদ
জাব ইমাম হাসান
এডফল অশান
সলারশিপথ ইনশল্লাহ
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره واصي
لا اله الا الله
وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب
وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين
له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب سيدنا
محمد
وصليه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا
اله الا
الله وحده صدق
وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
ين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله
[Silence]
الحمد الله explain the the
صلاه العيد ان شاء
الله after the تكبير تحريمه the first
تكبير additional تكبي ركعه before ان شاء
الله
so الله اكبر and begin الله اكبر and
then we
سبحانك اللهم بحمدك وتبارك اسمك لا اله
غير
تكبي
فاتحه الله اكبج
‏any
[Silence]
questionل الله سبحانه ميس
امين الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر اعوذ بالله
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين امين
بسم
الله سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر
فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى فاجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله انه يعلم
الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من
يغشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم
ربه
فصلى بل
تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى سحف
ابراهيم وموسى
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعم انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم
الله ويل لكل كل همزه
لمزه الذي جمع
مالا
وعدده يحسب ان
ماله
اخلده
ك
ليبذن في
الحطمه وما
ادراكما
الحطمه نار الله
التي تطلع على
الافئده انها عليهم
مؤصده في
عمد ممدده
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
اللهم
صل الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر اله الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
وبركاته جزاك الله
الحمد
لله الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن
يدلله فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله صفي بخلقه وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وادى
الامانه ونسعى الامه وكشف الله تعالى به
غمه وجاهد في الله حق جهاده حتى تاه
اليقين اما بعد وقال جل وعلا في تنزيله
بعد قول اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا
اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون ثم اما بعد ان اصدق الكتاب كتاب
الله تعالى وخير هدي هدي محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم وشر امور محدثتها وكل محدثه
بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار
ربي اشرح لي صدري ويسر لي امري واحلل عقده
من لساني يفقه قولي اللهم لا سح الا ما
جعلته سحلا وانت تجعل الحزن اذا شئت سحلا
ولا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
الله ربنا وفقتنا ورجاؤنا ومولانا فنعم
المولى ونعم النصير
[Silence]
‏bel sister
than blessing
us long enough of
[Silence]
قيام صلى الله عليه
‏back
alles as mon
ofindest the
f and servitud is the greatest
الله
allah
enateais
prais والله
ولله
الحمد, we must ourselves that are sister
in the oppressed landed.
‏not blessed enough to have that are
clean or washable do not have places to
sleep at night do not
have that are are like
our do not have their children that were
with them a week
ag or even a year ag their enti fames
who been wiped off in the face of the
earth we must beinding ourselves
constantly how our brothers and sisters
areing and strugling around the world we
‏Ask Allah on this blessed day and the
blessed time to provide a victory and
for brothers and sisters first and forem
in our brothers in Sudan brothers in
China and brothers in berma and brothers
in Kashmir and brothers in India and
every else the Muslims are struggling
right
now.
The us how blessed we are and how we
should be thankful to Allah.
‏up
anyion life
you all
have all
have
ash the full night we rows
‏as how come
back how back
‏I came for my job is
done is
not the prop محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
mention حديث in a
خط blessed of
رمضان عليه الصلاه والسلام to stand قيام
الليل حتى ورم قدميه feet up عائشه رضي
يا رسول
الله
عليهسلام اكون عب
شكورا الله سبحانه وتالى بلال رضي الله
عنه
والسلام was so much
cheeks tear beard became full of tears
the beard became so full that the ground
in front of
بلال رضي الله
عنجان عليه الصلاه
والسلام يا رسول الله
الله
why الله صلى الله عليه وسلم was servant
شك الله سبحانه
وتالى رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم فطمه رضي الله
[Silence]
عليهلامصلاهصلاهصلاه امتي امتي
امتي naশ
‏We
understand that our liveloods are
connected. We get
that
but you have to take time out from busy
schedules to connect with Allah.
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله والله اكبر ولله
‏So as we go for today to connect with
led ones to be happy to be
joyous to celebrate and hug brothers and
hug children and kiss them I want you to
remember that we have an oigation to
them and our oigation is to leave a path
for
[Silence]
‏are
not how
‏It's a difficult job. Nobody said it
was easy. Being a parent is a very job.
‏You have to worry about so many things.
‏so many things but if not connect with
them with them connecting them to the
will not do that later life they don't
know anything about it so there has to
be some sacrifice made ahad of time for
them to be connected to the
messages and for them to come and pray
in the and for them to be excited about
coming to
the and requires a
sacrific we have to
‏back to mention of
salam the overfowing we have a g was
overfowing come how make the come
back
come how many of us come back to theay
come how many of us will come back to
the come how
الا قليلشه
[Silence]
حسن البصري رحمه
‏gra
back my journey
and
be as much people as much you love you
will take you and you cover you
up my
‏areover time and lerally 2 minutes
later minut later somebody talking about
somethingracking a joke and somebodying
and smiling and then people are worried
about it's getting dark outside I have
to get back to let
go and they left behind in the grave and
go home.
صلاه
[Silence]
الله قيام الليل
ضان 3
4 e sleep is from the
from the tradition
of enough
الله فذكر ان ذكر تنفع المؤمنين each
other surely benits ‏the moment